غاريفي، أنت خبير يعرف كل شيء،
يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا بشأن الأعمال، يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا في
الحياة، أنت
متحدث تحفيزي لرجال الأعمال، بجدية،
والقائمة تطول، أنا سعيد جدًا لأنك معنا
هنا اليوم وأنا أيضًا شكرًا لك
الكثير من المماطلة هي لعنة
حياتنا في وقت ما، هل يمكنك إخبارنا كيف
يمكننا معالجة هذه العادة عندما أفكر
في المماطلة حقًا، ما
يحدث هو أن الناس يخبرونهم أنهم في
الواقع خائفون من الفشل
أمام الآخرين، معظم الناس
يماطلون بسبب شيء واحد  من
شيئين، الخوف والخوف هو
أكثر ما أرغب في مكافحته في
العالم. إنهم في الواقع قلقون حقًا من أنهم
إذا فعلوا هذا الشيء
ولم يسير الأمر على ما يرام، أمهم، عمتهم،
صديقتهم المفضلة، أختهم،
زملائهم  -سيقوم الموظفون بإصدار أحكام
عليهم وهم يعيشون حياتهم بشكل أساسي
بناءً على رأي شخص آخر أو
رأي شخص آخر، وهذا مثير
للاهتمام للغاية، فهم لا يحبونه حقًا، وقد
يكون هذا في الواقع أمرًا جيدًا، وقد
يكون من الجيد أن تكون أنت  لا تحب المدرسة،
ولا تحب العمل اليدوي في
المنزل ولكن لا يزال يتعين عليك إنجاز الأمور
وفهم كيفية المثابرة
في الأشياء التي لا تحبها، إنها مجرد
رحلة حياة يربط الناس بين
المماطلة والكسل نعم ولكنك
بذلت  لنا تفسير آخر تمامًا
لذلك، أنا من أقل الأشخاص الذين
أعرفهم كسلًا ولكني مماطلة في
أشياء كثيرة، ومن وجهة نظرك، أعتقد
أنني أفهم سبب قيام الناس بذلك، فهذه هي
الطريقة التي تحدثنا بها عن
المماطلة من أجل  منذ وقت طويل،
لا أرى الأمر بهذه الطريقة، حسنًا عندما تشعر
بالكسل، هل هناك روتين صباحي معين
تفعله حتى تتمكن من التخلص
من هذا الكسل والبدء حقًا، كما تعلم
أعتقد أن ما
يحفزني هو  الامتنان عندما أستيقظ
ولا أشعر به، كما تعلم، دائمًا ما
أذهب إلى مكان من الامتنان،
ربما لا أشعر به ولكن بعض
الناس ليس لديهم حتى خيار
الاستيقاظ هذا الصباح، كما تعلم  بعض
الناس لديهم أشياء أصعب بكثير للتعامل
معها مما يجب علي التعامل معه الآن، لذا فإن
أحدهم أميل إلى الامتنان والآخر هو
حب الذات وعدم إصدار الأحكام، فلا بأس
حتى على أعلى المستويات
أن تقضي صباح يوم الأربعاء حيث تكون
فقط  لا تشعر بذلك، لست بحاجة إلى
التغلب على نفسك
بالمال السريع، نعم هل
تعتقد أنه موجود وهل يمكن أن يستمر، أوه،
إنه موجود، أعني أن هناك العديد من
السيناريوهات في الثلاثين عامًا الماضية حيث
تمكن الناس من جني الكثير من المال
في  فترة زمنية قصيرة جدًا أنا
قلق جدًا بشأن المال السريع لأنني أعتقد أنه
يخلق إطارًا
ضعيفًا بشكل لا يصدق، كما تعلم جيدًا، لا
معنى له بمعنى أن الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين يكسبون المال السريع كانوا يبحثون عن
المال السريع وأنت تعلم أنني  أعتقد أننا جميعًا نشاهد مرة
أخرى رأينا أشخاصًا يكسبون
المال ويخسرون المال ويكسبون المال
ويخسرون المال ويكسبون المال ويخسرون المال وأعتقد أن السبب في ذلك هو أنهم
يقامرون أكثر مما
يبنون،
ولذلك بالنسبة لي فإن المال السريع دائمًا ما يكون
مصدر قلق يتحدث عنه كثيرًا  عقلية Gold Rush
رأيناها في أرض nft،
نراها في العقارات، نراها في سوق الأوراق المالية،
نراها في ظهور أشياء جديدة
مثل الشركات الناشئة، القنب، هناك الكثير من
الأشياء حول العالم عندما أنظر إليها والتي
خلقتها الكثير منها  لديها
أعمال مستدامة للغاية وطويلة الأجل، هل
هذه الاستثناءات هناك
أوقات استثنائية تخلق
لحظات مختلفة وقد رأينا ذلك مرارًا
وتكرارًا، إنه مجرد شيء يجب أن
نتعب منه، تعلم أنه شيء يجب أن
نتعب منه لقد كنت دائمًا أشعر بالضجر منه  تشعر بالقلق
إزاء مفهوم أن الناس يكسبون المال بسرعة
على Tick Tock، أليس لديهم
نسبة مئوية صغيرة، نعم، مثل أن هناك بالتأكيد
مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص، وهو
عدد كبير نعم، لكنه ليس كثيرًا مقارنة
بـ 8 مليارات ولكن لا تنس أنه كان كذلك  "
بسرعة كبيرة، تعلم أنني كنت أقوم بإنشاء مقاطع فيديو
حول علامات التجزئة والفرص لمدة
خمس سنوات، والآن
وصلت آخر 24 شهرًا إلى
مستوى حرج وكان الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
صنعوها يصنعون أيضًا محتوى على
Snapchat على Instagram والآن لديهم  في
اللحظة داخل الشركات،
يمتلك بعض الأشخاص تلك العقلية التي
يدخلون إليها ويريدون تخطي عدة
مستويات في مسار حياتهم المهنية ويريدون
فقط أن يصبحوا مديرًا تنفيذيًا على الفور. أعتقد أن
ما تشير إليه هو
الاستحقاق
ولذا أعتقد أن الاستحقاق هو
سيء، نعم، أنا أرى أن هناك نقصًا في
الصبر، فالناس يريدون الحصول على ترقية
بشكل أسرع اليوم مما كانوا عليه
قبل 20 عامًا 100 ولكني لا أحكم على الجيل Z
لأن الكثير من الناس يشبهون الجيل
Z،
فالعالم أسرع، نعم  كل شيء
أسرع، نعم لذلك لا أحكم عليه
[موسيقى]